me my girl gun dude yeah it sounds so
stupid man
yeah we got like 99 oh don't get me
started which one do you think not today
beyonce
bring it wait i love it i hope you're
watching nowadays now say the other way
yes these don't get me started
this is all i've been talking about in
my pocket oh really yeah because this
these people are bananas
okay so one one chick she's 60. okay
the white chicken the dwight street
she's 60. with the indians in love with
who's living at home he's supposedly
living at home and he can't
he's in her then he can come to find out
he's married married you know
and she gave up her whole life nothing
to go move out to [ __ ] india with
this
and it's so obvious i mean it's so weird
because she's like
she's 60 bro and like oh everybody's
assistant
look at that this is what it is
but do you when they get with this he
gets around his buddies they all they
see her and they're all
what the [ __ ] bro like they're literally
like dude what are you doing yeah what
is he doing
well how about how about the black girl
how about the black can i say though
with them
i actually feel like they have feelings
for each other
but this guy is a coward a hundred
percent he's a coward because
he uses whoa that is not great
oh that looks like he's i mean he's not
a dreamboat
but yeah they look like they're on a
field trip you know what i mean like
uh
but he's a coward and to me he used this
show
as a way to spite his family and
yeah and they arranged a marriage and
everything i think he used the show and
he used this woman as a way of being
like
this i can't come to my father and be
like i don't want to be in an arranged
marriage
so i'm going to do it this way i'm going
to embarrass myself my family whole
family everything
in this woman so but this is nine day
fiance the other way so it's americans
going to foreign but usually nine day
fiance is foreign america like
my favorite is though is the white girl
and the dude from africa
oh no the south africa the guy from
south africa
yeah who's like okay no no that's
different wait i'm talking about the
black dude set up the show for me people
come from another game
no no no no no 90 day fiance is just
about you you know
people people fall in love and then
internet you have to get married in 90
days to get a visa to stay in the
country
so and not today usually it's like
craziness like this
like she's from like alabama and he's
from
like uh nigeria but she comes over the
new season
yeah it's good though yeah i haven't got
to the new season oh yeah oh yeah but
but so
are they already dating before the show
or they meet on the show they're dating
i think that what it is is they they i
think that fiance puts out a wide
like like net of like hey are you
falling in love with some that kind of
thing
and then they start filming it but i'm
still on the first season
and what okay let me explain see the
original night of day fiance
it'll be some this is usually how it is
80 of the time
it's some hot foreign girl guy and they
want to come to the united states
and so on the internet they fall in love
with some monster
right okay okay yeah it's a [ __ ] mom
i'm following you so far
some fried food monster man okay yes so
then what happens is
they go through this process they come
over to get you know and it's it just
doesn't work
okay and you can see it all right or
now and then they for them come to
america now on occasion
the one person like remember nicole and
azan okay
nicole is this pretty face fat girl
okay that's the that's her description
all right she's got a pretty face
but she's fat okay and the dude
there they are all right she got a
pretty face yeah that's a pretty face
she has kids but all her pictures are
like this you ain't gonna see like
this picture would take up the rest of
the screen okay big girl she's a big
girl
now as in is this they look like the
number 10. each other look
at that yeah they look like this okay
she go
she's going this is what i can't stand
about this show like she's spending
all her money on this dude in morocco
sending her money sending him money to
open up a store okay
she's gonna take her daughter and decide
i'm gonna take my daughter and go move
to
morocco with this dude that's my problem
when this [ __ ] she's lost a lot
of weight by the way too when she when
he's got up when she got off the plane
he was like you know the little
confessional that they do
oh no this [ __ ] is like that
he's like uh she
was a lot bigger yeah you know she's
bigger than i thought
jw was like she's bigger way bigger than
i thought he did because every picture
is like this
then he takes but they on facetiming and
stuff but just the face
then he takes her on a hike does that
sound like a match
no okay and she takes you on the hype
struggling the hike is a disaster
okay in morocco but she's just sweating
but she's
she's honest as [ __ ] she says i told you
i don't want to work out
you know she says that right and i'm
like this ain't a match
no that doesn't look like a hike that
looks like you're going to bury a bottle
you know what i mean let's morocco hide
you
so my problem with it is when they when
the kids are involved
so she's taking that this was a disaster
oh that's what that's what i said yeah
stop being
lazy and she's like [ __ ] i told you
he's got this chick on the walter payton
workout yeah
if i'm fat like that i'm a big guy yeah
all right i get off the plane
you see i'm fat this is what you get
[ __ ] yeah okay i'm going to hike
ain't going off [ __ ] obviously i
don't hype i think hiking hiking's not
my
goal to take me to the near where we eat
yeah just got off the [ __ ] plate wait
did she bring her kid with her
yeah she did oh dude this whole thing
it's trash but by the way
on the other version on 90 day fiance
the other way that dude daniel and
whatever her name is dude from south
africa
no oh yeah yeah yeah i can't stand her
okay let me let me let me tell you that
let me tell you something right does it
ever work
no no no which one is it it's uh right
there right now the second picture
second picture
boom all right this guy's got a gambling
problem
okay he he gambled away all his money he
got into some illegal [ __ ] because of
his gambling problem
he didn't tell her all the things they
have fallen in love okay he goes to
rehab
she says all right i'm gonna their first
meet their first real
interact thing now is she's gonna go
bring her eight-year-old son
meet him out of rehab okay and to get
married
all right and then move to south africa
but her whole thing is like
i'm never going to trust you damn [ __ ]
why are you here yeah
like like you're dragging the kid into
it like exactly like it's like like
she's talking
okay wait wait no no that's her kid
here's my previous and
by the way she got the kid calling him
dad
okay so you're going you're gonna set
your kid up where you're bonded with
this guy
but you're gonna go see him and be like
one i don't like this place
two i'm never gonna trust you and three
get pregnant on purpose
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] out and then what
listen if you are deciding to
take someone back if you go
you [ __ ] up but i'm gonna give you
another chance
you have to then give them the other
chance you gotta drop
you also have to drop you have to drop
if you're saying i'm giving you another
chance
you can't talk to me about this every
day
and she's like well you've made
decisions and i'm thinking to myself you
brought your [ __ ] eight-year-old son
to south
dangerous ass south africa tragic and
then you want to blame him and at the
same time be like let's have a baby
and then be on him like you're making
bad choices dude the [ __ ] out
i can't wait to watch this [ __ ] i
haven't seen it
we're loading you up wait wait wait
loading don't watch it i've never
watched it
the other way is the joint i like both
of them like did you ever see homeboy he
was from
somewhere mid-america and then he
marries the brazilian and gets her
pregnant
and then goes there and they're filming
in her hometown some little [ __ ]
like hold on place and the camera crew
and him get robbed at night at knife
point
they steal the cameras because you're
like you're in the favelas of brazil
yeah they have these cameras and even
she goes i don't think he's smart they
steal her phone they take her phone
they take all the camera gear by the way
that's by the way by the way fantastic
wait wait wait
this is something else that's crazy
about this [ __ ] yeah that's them okay
this is
the one they went to that they went to
brazil straight brazilian but doesn't
speak english they
only communicate like that yeah but
here's something that's crazy all right
the crazy part
regular 90-day fiance like i said
you have the hot one and the monster
mm-hmm every time okay now that the
other way
the hot one is convincing the monster to
move to their [ __ ] town it doesn't make
sense
and and bring all their money yeah
so it's even more crazy it's even more
crazy
because it's one guy they're the real
dumbass one guy the one guy corey
yes this guy this one this [ __ ]
corey
he this this another crazy one too this
guy is a little this guy's a little like
are most of people not from the states
they
it's never that the people in the states
don't have money and the people from out
of the country is it always the people
from the state
it's all with the money's always in
america oh okay every guy
all right all right so let me tell you
about corey oh this [ __ ] okay
so he is mormon all right
he mormon hemorrhoids all right
not just ecuador okay these people live
in
third world countries yeah and they live
in the third world part
of the third world like they sleep on
like that ain't even living in a good
part of the world yeah yeah
okay that's right i mean with the good
fans i mean
listen they don't got the good fan okay
now corey
he sends this woman 40 000 of his
savings it's his whole life savings
to go live with her all right he's going
to move his whole life
now just listen i i don't like calling
women
[ __ ] all right i like to say [ __ ] a
lot but i don't mean [ __ ] yeah i mean
[ __ ]
yeah because i just say [ __ ] [ __ ] you
a [ __ ] yeah okay
this chick's a [ __ ]
i talked about this on my list he went
to go visit her
to move three planes
she wasn't at the airport what
and this is her on the phone you're a
big boy you should take the bus
the bus he had to take a bus and she
gave her 40 grand
remember yeah yeah 40 grand hey you know
what that does for her
you're at the airport if i'm coming oh i
would have rode the bus
dear just a [ __ ] you know oh my
god all right so when he gets there
she's not bad though she gets there
she's not she's like an ecuador seven
yeah come on let's be real ecuador
i've never heard look she
she ain't wearing his wedding ring she
ain't wearing the promise ring
she's told him numerous times i don't
want to get married
and then i don't even blame her when she
came to america to visit the mormon
the the place she was like this sucks
yep
she's like i don't want to be mormon i
don't want to live like this
and you know what i was with her yep
because he lived on some [ __ ] farm
in the middle of some [ __ ] place how
do they how do they how do these people
connect
the internet so they've they've
connected over online
but he loves her and they communicate
that she treats him like [ __ ] dude did
you see the the tell-all episode
i'm sure you know okay she's in ecuador
he's on the set first of all she says
we're not getting married yet because
you're too fat god
damn but she doesn't have and she's not
on the spectrum and she's you know she's
an [ __ ] that's what i'm saying
autistic me she's got nothing
he gave her a wedding ring and she saw
she accepted now this is the tell-all
show and she's there and she's going
like this
not no ring on like on purpose kind of
being
like just brazen like i'm not wearing
your ring
what's this dude doing all this time
that's what i'm saying man i just i
don't get it they're just suckers
what they're saying you know what you
know what and all these guys on that
show
they're all mama's boys [ __ ] like you
know what i can't stand to
when a mom and when a parent goes and
this goes to all of y'all out there this
is just for people in general all you
[ __ ]
oh all you [ __ ] out there if
you're a parent
okay and your kid is 30
living at home yeah i don't want to hear
your mouth
talking about you need to be a man josh
oh i agree no
treat them like a [ __ ] man i agree
dude
when you get to the near season there
are so many problems all these guys
living with their mom and their mom's
like you know you need to start taking
responsibility there's a word there's
there's one i'm not gonna sweat for you
there's one dude he
there's one dude dating a brazilian and
his mom refuses to let him go
without her going he brings her and it
is a
nightmare dude of course when i get off
stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son